After years of waiting, Star Wars fans can
now officially see The Rise of Skywalker,
the final chapter of an iconic franchise that's
spanned nine films and inspired several generations
of movie-goers.
But unfortunately for viewers in the United
Arab Emirates, there's a certain piece of
this sprawling galactic tale that they won't
be able to see.
The United Arab Emirates has a population
of more than nine million, and is among several
areas within the surrounding regions where
members of the LGBTQ+ community have limited
or extremely restrictive rights.
Homosexuality is officially illegal in several
countries within the Middle East, and as a
result, same-gender relationships are rarely,
if ever, portrayed in films.
Several people who have seen The Rise of Skywalker
in Dubai, the United Arab Emirates' most populous
city, have told The Hollywood Reporter that
they weren't able to watch the series' first
same-sex kiss.
Taking place at the end of the film and featuring
Commander Larma D'Acy and her wife, Resistance
pilot Wrobie Tyce, the moment marks a historic
first for the Star Wars franchise, but one
completely removed for UAE viewers.
This wouldn't mark the first time the UAE
and neighboring regions have censored a scene,
or even an entire movie, based on its representation
of LGBTQ+ identities.
In 2013, a version of Wolf of Wall Street,
had around 45 minutes cut out entirely, essentially
rendering the moving unviewable for many who
tried to watch it.
And in 2011, both Black Swan and Love and
Other Drugs were banned by the country's censors,
while Ang Lee's Brokeback Mountain was banned
in the UAE in 2005 after a four-month review,
with the final decision made based on the
country's laws against homosexuality.
Recently, Black Panther earned the distinction
of being the first film to screen theatrically
in Saudi Arabia after the country lifted a
35-year ban on movie screenings.
However, a kiss between stars Chadwick Boseman
and Lupita Nyong'o was cut from its run in
the country, following a very difficult negotiation
during which Saudi Arabian officials requested
so much of the film be removed that Disney
was convinced it wouldn't have been worth
showing at all.
While the scene may have been removed from
the UAE run of The Rise of Skywalker, it surprisingly
wasn't censored in China, which also has a
long history of eliminating on-screen portrayals
of LGBTQ+ identity.
Reports from movie attendees in both Beijing
and Shanghai confirmed that moment had been
retained, though China had notoriously banned
Brokeback Mountain, and cut Michael Fassbender's
same-sex kiss from Alien: Covenant.
But while some audiences around the world
who got to see the moment in Rise of Skywalker
moment celebrated it, others outright blasted
it, especially after director J.J. Abrams
had hinted at the importance of the moment
earlier, during the film's press tour, telling
Variety,
"In the case of the LGBTQ community, it was
important to me that people who go to see
this movie feel that they're being represented
in the film."
But it wasn't quite the representation that
many fans had asked for.
For years, a group of viewers had openly shared
their hopes of seeing the final trilogy's
leading men, Poe Dameron and Finn, spark a
canonical romantic connection.
Actor Oscar Isaac revealed that while he had
no control over that particular character
development decision, he hoped for the films
to take Finn and Poe's relationship in a romantic
direction.
John Boyega also spurred fan interest in a
relationship between the two characters before
the latest film's debut, sharing a cheeky
Instagram video in which he penned a long-winded,
romantic letter to his "dearest Oscar."
"Bro, I think, lo-key, sometimes I feel BB-8
is straight up is jealous of our s---."
While fans may not have gotten the exact romantic
relationship they were hoping for, many have
excitedly come out in support of the on-screen
moment they were given, with just as many
fans wishing that the moment lasted longer,
or wasn't confined to background characters.
In an industry where LGBTQ+ representation
isn't internationally accepted, what's clear
from the fan response and the UAE's decision
to cut the historic moment is that the film
was never going to please The Rise of Skywalker's
entire audience.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Rise
of Skywalker are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.